you can use it you you can use it to
justify a belief that conflict is right
in the sense of you know if i take not
this an uncontroversial example like
sierra leone right we're british sent in
the troops to rescue the government
there now you can say is a person of
faith i find it objectionable that we
allow this regime to tumble well let me
give it a different example which which
i think bill clinton often users in
respect of why these decisions are very
difficult actually which is rwanda you
know there might have been people of
faith who would have said actually you
should intervene necessary militarily in
this situation certainly I would take
that view um does faith justify conflict
in the sense of a conflict for the
purposes of your faith which is a
different question i would say on the
whole no it doesn't so you know why were
the Crusades wrong while they were wrong
because that's what they were about why
is terrorism in the name of the
establishing some religious caliphate
wrong you know is it i mean it's it's
it's wrong to trying to establish faith
by the faith perspective by those means
so i would say no in in in terms of the
justification for action now in terms
faith itself as the reason for it faith
giving you values that mean you seek to
intervene that's different